I like the mustache by the way it looks
like you're going to be making
pornography and Quarantine everybody
else has mentioned that there's a rise
in watching for notarized and sexual
activity I notice that my wife oh is
that true been very experimental with me
oh you're trying new stuff with the wife
yeah she she showed me this new thing
the other night that was bananas and you
have to try this especially with your
Crazy Legs you hold yourself up you like
his leg beneath you
yes you do the boobs wait I'm just like
what is happening wait so I've seized
that and I do the moves so you get
basically almost a push-up position or a
plank as you do and then it's a lot of
dipping and dipping so this is going to
require a lot of core strength on my
part yeah you got to prepare for this
prepare like two three months get your
body ready and then 20-second play you
can do this yeah well my my wife thinks
that we should stay six feet apart
you've been saying that since Obama's
first term joke there is it's not
related to coronavirus kind of a
loveless marriage
did you ever huh sometimes you go up in
tone for no reason I don't know why what
do you got baby my son is bringing me
the coffee you want to see how to code
it tell Sonny that uncle Coney says hi
honey how are you I'm gonna you bored
are you having fun um tell Cody how much
daddy's been screaming lately
[Laughter]
yeah I told him about that with the dog
I wasn't screaming at her I was trying
to get my point across
she called me JC it's a true story
that's a true story so he really did
scream at a woman who was I was trying
to get her attention she had something
here I think your father was in the
right we have to maintain social
distancing and I think your father did
the right thing sunny she was very nice
and I told her I'm trying to tell her
I'm sorry hey tell Cody what I hate
Conant when we past your house swear to
God I'm telling you the truth whenever
we pass your house walking to do what
daddy does also the other night we were
practicing the Sandler flop and then get
the hell out of you ready you want to do
the thing already there we go go okay
thank you I love you thanks for that
coffee
say goodbye honey yeah bye papi by the
way Cody if you want what you know let's
get a shout-out to that coffee company
who makes it I don't know but it tastes
like Italy Billy that's good coffee
let's get the word out on that you know
we got to get people employed you know
thank you to all the businesses staying
open and the food and that people being
so cool and serving us food in grocery
stores and restaurants that are staying
open just for us and then drop dropping
an offer or let you know be a nice stop
people bringing it out are you know I
can't believe I thank you so much I
really it's an amazing thing you do like
you I'm thinking about a lot of these
small businesses we know a lot of these
people because we see them all the time
at different restaurants waiters that
help us out you wonder how are they
getting along and so we've got to be
figuring that out as we go and not to
take care of each other yeah absolutely
and I hope this gets done real soon I
hope so man it's it's heartbreaking
heartbreak
made a people of Italy I explained speak
Thai you know I did
in Italy and would with Jennifer Aniston
and we got friendly with so many people
in Italy I'm getting so many texts from
them praying for you guys and they give
me updates all the time and it's just
the terrible but love to everybody and
around the world
yeah did you see some of the footage
coming from Italy is really beautiful
like people like going out on balconies
and singing oh really wonderful it's
really heartwarming yeah the science
would sing in at a certain time and
everybody's singing along it was the
trend everybody had good voices
it seems yeah I don't know if we have
the equivalent here in America I was
like I am I am the equivalent of that
with just like you know the golden voice
God gave me if you want a cold and I
can't a sting a little opera maybe this
will spread good to you around the world
I know yeah if you've got some opera for
us that would be lovely
so I'll just hold a note real long and
see if anyone's you know one holds a
note better than you you want to hear
hear me really oh I didn't warm up this
morning but I'll get it to you all right
this is for the world right now all
right
three two one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you okay no I have one question for
you Adam why is it that when you're
singing you pose like a monster Oh
[Laughter]